a face-to-face conversation and no bad
blood but what did James shockingly say
about Henry Cavill not being Superman
anymore the DC extended Universe has
officially been nuked with Henry Cavill
and the rest of the Justice League crew
being given new marching orders from
Warner Brothers over the past few months
and in cavill's case he's marching right
out the Studio's front door now Weeks
Later DC Studios co-head James Gunn has
finally decided to clear the air about
the entire caval situation or how he
views it at least for those who might
have missed what happened last year DC's
extended Universe went on The Chopping
Block in late 2022 after gum was hired
to do Studio resuscitation for Warner
Brothers along with co-head Peter Safran
right from the start people expected the
new DC Studios Duo to flip the entire DC
EU on its head but here's where the
controversy comes in Cavill on October
24 2022 posted a video on his Instagram
page announcing his return to the dceu
as Superman just one day before it was
announced that gun and saffron would
lead the DC film division at Warner
Brothers he even appeared in a
mid-credit scene for Black Adam little
did the mission impossible Fallout tag
to know that the Duo's DC creative
Wheels were already spinning and
changing direction rapidly according to
Gunn there was never a plan in place for
Cavill to return a Superman before his
departure was announced in December 2022
back
speaking of the private press event on
January 30th and which DC Studios
announced its new movie slate James Gunn
claimed that the Henry Cavill casting
controversy was actually not much of a
controversy at all because caval was
never Hired Gun told reporters we didn't
fire Henry Henry was never cast he added
Henry was just not hired to be Superman
in the Superman movie there was never a
deal there for another movie now on the
surface of the caval sacking it would
appear that DC Studios had invited the
actor back and asked him to announce his
return before the James Gunn and Peter
saffron eye ring was made public but to
say that Cavill was never hired is a bit
of a stretch since cavil said publicly
that Warner Brothers had asked him to
return a Superman for future projects
needless to say DC fans are ticked off
about it one Twitter user blasted off a
tweet saying so James Gunn straight up
calling Henry Cavill a liar good to know
another tweeted this is why to always
get something in writing before you
commit yourself to something they've
really effed Henry over with that
announcement from the beginning DC fans
thought the entire Cavill situation was
wrong and handled poorly back in
December 2022 a Twitter user wrote I'm a
James Gunn fan but firing Henry Cavill
after he let go of Witcher to play
Superman again as villain Behavior
meanwhile gunnin says that there's no
bad blood towards caval on his end and
that is all just part of his job
speaking Monday night at the private
press event James Gunn claimed to be a
fan of Henry Cavill and insisted that a
decision to go in a different direction
with Superman was strictly business
for me it's about who do I want to cast
to Superman and who do the filmmakers we
have want to cast and for me for this
story it isn't Henry this Superman is
not Henry for a number of reasons Gunn
who is very vocal on social media
revealed in a December Twitter post that
he was very truthful to Cavill
throughout the entire goodbye process
Gunn noted that we had a face-to-face
conversation with caval before the news
broke tweeting I'm anything but cold
about it we had a very open and honest
and respectful discussion we've
communicated since and he and I are all
good speaking on Monday night gun showed
his admiration for Cavill and what he's
been through with Warner Brothers over
the past few months which he ultimately
blamed on his predecessors Gunn said I
like Henry I think he's a great guy I
think he's getting drowned by a lot of
people including the former regime of
this company as for what the future now
holds at DC gun and Peter saffron have
announced several new movies and
projects for the DC Universe reboot
including new Batman Superman and
Supergirl movies a Swamp Thing project
and much more overall the DC Studios
roadmap looks bright and it's only a
matter of time before we find out he
will eventually be filling caval's shoes
as the last son of Krypton
[Music]